>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Good morning.
>> I'm Karen Jaffe.
I'm head of the Young
Readers Center.
And how many here are
from JO Wilson Elementary?
All right, fifth grade, right?
>> Yes.
>> Have any of you been to the
Library of Congress before?
>> No.
>> Great! We're very
glad to have you today.
So you're in for several treats.
The first is, you're at
the Library of Congress.
The second is that you're in the
Young Readers Center at the Library
of Congress, which is a
special library just for kids
up to about 16 years old.
We were started about seven
years ago because it was--
lots of people felt that
it wasn't fair that kids
under 16 couldn't come and
read a book at the library.
Because to get a book, you have
to have a reader's card,
and you have to be 16.
So we have three rooms, we have
lots of books, we have games,
we have special programs like today,
we're open Monday through Friday,
9:00 to 4:30 and some
special holidays.
So we hope you'll come
again, maybe with school,
maybe with your families, okay?
Today is part of a special
celebration at the Library
of Congress in honor
of Alice in Wonderland.
Who's heard of Alice in Wonderland?
Okay. Alice in Wonderland, the book,
is celebrating the
150th anniversary.
Now, believe it or not, the Library
of Congress is older than that.
The institution is 215.
So we're a little bit
older than Alice.
But that's okay.
So we've been celebrating Alice
in Wonderland the month of April.
And with us today is a very special
organization called The Lewis
Carroll Society.
And some of the people
are sitting behind you.
And two of the people are
sitting up here that I'm going
to introduce in a minute.
And we're going to
have a special read
from a very popular
chapter in the book.
But also at the end, if you have
some questions, you might ask about,
ask our readers, what is
The Lewis Carroll Society?
I think I'll ask them to do that at
the end and not at the beginning.
And what is a book collector?
Because some of The Lewis Carroll
Society members, many of them,
I think, collect books and collect
things related to Lewis and Carroll.
And that's a very interesting
either vocation or avocation.
It could be a career,
it could be a hobby.
And one of the things we do with
our Everybody Wins D.C. programs,
which is our other partner
here today, who organized you,
is we try to introduce
students to different careers,
different things they can think
about doing when they grow up.
So today, we're combining a book
and a very special celebration,
and we're also talking about
the career and the avocation
of being bill collectors, okay?
So the two readers
for you today are Ken
and Ellie Salins, and
they are members.
They're also related.
And they're members of
The Lewis Carroll Society.
And they are going
to start the read.
And one more important thing.
At the end of this program,
The Lewis Carroll Society has
purchased a copy of the book,
a special copy of the
book, for each of you.
And the reason it's special
is because there are many,
many versions of Alice
in Wonderland,
and you've probably seen a movie or
television or other kinds of books
that some of them look
different from others.
But the one they're giving you
has the original illustrations
by John Tenniel.
So that's very special, as well.
So now I'm going to
introduce the Salins.
>> Ellie Salins: Thank you.
Hi, everybody.
Thank you for coming.
I wanted to first explain that
this is the Maxine Shaffer memorial
reading, and The Lewis Carroll
Society has this memorial reading
every time we have a meeting.
So we have meetings twice a year.
Usually once a year
to New York City,
and then the other time it's
anywhere else in the country.
Or it could be out in the country.
We've had readings in Canada before.
So this time, it's in
Washington, D.C. in Maryland.
And this is the Maxine
Shaffer memorial reading.
And Maxine Shaffer was the secretary
of The Lewis Carroll Society
from when it started in 1974.
Thank you, 1974.
Until about 1994 when
she decided to retire.
And then she died shortly
after that in 1996.
But she really ran the society.
She did a whole lot to
get the society started.
And we have these readings
in her memory.
And she was my mother.
My father is in the back there.
Wave. And so we're here in
honor of her, but also in honor
of Alice and Lewis Carroll.
So what we're going to do--
and this is my husband, Ken,
so it's all in the family.
We're going to do a reading from
the Mad Hatter's tea party chapter.
Do you all know that
chapter of the book?
>> No.
>> Ellie Salins: No?
You will learn it soon.
But we're going to-- there's about
a couple different characters,
and there's only two of us.
So I'm going to be a narrator.
And I'm also Alice,
and I'm the Dormouse.
>> Ken Salins: And
I'll be a narrator
and the Mad Hatter
and the March Hare.
It might get a little confusing.
We'll try to do maybe a
little different voice.
>> Ellie Salins: We'll make it work.
Okay, and here we go.
Thank you for being here.
>> Ken Salins: There was a table
set out under a tree in front
of the house, and the March Hare and
the Hatter were having tea at it.
A Dormouse was sitting
between them, fast asleep,
and the other two were using it as a
cushion, resting their elbows on it,
and talking over its head.
>> Ellie Salins: Very uncomfortable
for the Dormouse, only,
as it's asleep, I suppose
it doesn't mind.
>> Ken Salins: No room!
No room!
>> Ellie Salins: They cried out.
>> Ken Salins: When
they saw Alice coming.
>> Ellie Salins: There's
plenty of room!
>> Ken Salins: Have some wine.
>> Ellie Salins: I
don't see any wine.
>> Ken Salins: There isn't any.
>> Ellie Salins: Then it wasn't
very civil of you to offer it.
>> Ken Salins: It wasn't
very civil of you to sit
down without being invited.
>> Ellie Salins: I didn't
know it was your table.
It's laid for a great
many more than three.
>> Ken Salins: Your
hair wants cutting.
>> Ellie Salins: Said the Hatter.
>> Ken Salins: He's been
looking at Alice for some time
with great curiosity, and
this was his first speech.
>> Ellie Salins: You should learn
not to make personal remarks.
It's very rude.
>> Ken Salins: Why is a
raven like a writing-desk?
>> Ellie Salins: Come, we
shall have some fun now!
I'm glad they've begun
asking riddles.
I believe I can guess that.
>> Ken Salins: Do you mean that you
think you can find the answer to it?
>> Ellie Salins: Exactly so.
>> Ken Salins: Then you
should say what you mean.
>> Ellie Salins: I do.
At least I mean what I say.
That's the same thing, you know.
>> Ken Salins: Not
the same thing a bit.
You might just as well say
that I see what I eat is the
same thing as I eat what I see.
You might just as well say that I
like what I get is the same
thing as I get what I like.
>> Ellie Salins: You
might as well say--
>> Ken Salins: Added the Dormouse,
who seemed to be talking
in his sleep.
>> Ellie Salins: That I breathe
when I sleep is the same thing
as I sleep when I breathe.
>> Ken Salins: It is
the same thing with you.
>> Ellie Salins: Here,
the conversation dropped,
and the party sat silent for
a minute, while Alice thought
over all she could
remember about ravens
and writing desks,
which wasn't much.
>> Ken Salins: What
day of the month is it?
>> Ellie Salins: The Hatter had
done his watch out of his pocket.
>> Ken Salins: And was looking at
it uneasily, shaking it every now
and then, and holding it to his ear.
>> Ellie Salins: The fourth.
>> Ken Salins: Two days wrong.
I told you butter wouldn't
suit the works.
It was the best butter, yes,
but some crumbs must
have gotten in as well.
You shouldn't have put it
in with the bread knife.
>> Ellie Salins: The March Hare took
the watch and looked at it gloomily.
Then he dipped it into his cup
of tea and looked at it again.
But he could think of nothing
better to say than his first remark.
>> Ken Salins: It was the
best butter, you know?
>> Ellie Salins: What a funny watch.
It tells the days of the month, and
it doesn't tell what o'clock it is.
>> Ken Salins: Why should it?
Does your watch tell
you what year it is?
>> Ellie Salins: Of course not.
But that's because it stays here
for such a long time together.
>> Ken Salins: Which is
just the case with mine.
>> Ellie Salins: I
don't quite understand.
>> Ken Salins: The
Dormouse is sleeping again.
>> Ellie Salins: Said the Hatter.
>> Ken Salins: And he poured a
little hot tea upon its nose.
>> Ellie Salins: Of
course, of course,
just what I was going
to remark myself.
>> Ken Salins: Have you
guessed the riddle yet?
>> Ellie Salins: No, I give up.
What's the answer?
>> Ken Salins: I haven't
the slightest idea.
Nor I.
>> Ellie Salins: I think you might
do something better with the time
than waste it looking for
riddles that have no answer.
>> Ken Salins: If you
knew time as well as I do,
you wouldn't talk about wasting it.
It's him.
>> Ellie Salins: I don't
know what you mean.
>> Ken Salins: Of course you don't.
I dare say you never
even spoke to time.
>> Ellie Salins: Perhaps
not, but I know I have
to beat time when I learn music.
>> Ken Salins: Ah,
that accounts for it!
He won't stand beating.
Now, if you only kept
on good terms with him,
he'd do almost anything
you liked with the clock.
For instance, suppose it
were 9:00 in the morning,
just time to begin lessons.
You only have to whisper a hint
to time, and around goes the clock
in a twinkling, half waste
one, time for dinner.
>> Ellie Salins: That
would be grand, certainly.
But then I shouldn't be
hungry for it, you know?
>> Ken Salins: Not
at first, perhaps.
But you could keep it to half
past one, as long as you'd like.
>> Ellie Salins: Is
that the way you manage?
>> Ken Salins: Not I.
We quarreled last March just
before he went mad, you know?
And it was at the great concert
given by the Queen of Hearts,
and I had to sing twinkle
twinkle little bat,
how I wonder what you're at.
You know the song perhaps.
>> Ellie Salins: I've
heard something like it.
>> Ken Salins: It goes,
when you know, in this way,
up above the world you fly
like a tea tray in the sky.
Twinkle twinkle.
>> Ellie Salins: Here,
the Dormouse shook itself
and began singing in its sleep.
Twinkle, twinkle, twinkle,
twinkle, twinkle.
>> Ken Salins: And went on so long.
>> Ellie Salins: That they had
to pinch it to make it stop.
>> Ken Salins: Well, I had hardly
finished off the first verse
when the queen jumped up and bawled
out, "he's murdering the time!
Off with his head!"
>> Ellie Salins: How
dreadfully savage.
>> Ken Salins: And ever since
that, he won't do a thing I ask.
It's always 6:00 there.
>> Ellie Salins: Is that
the reason that there's
so many tea things are put out here?
>> Ken Salins: Yes, that's it.
It's always tea time, and we have no
time to watch things between whiles.
>> Ellie Salins: Then you
keep moving around, I suppose.
>> Ken Salins: Exactly so.
As the things used up.
>> Ellie Salins: But what
happens when you come
around to the beginning again?
>> Ken Salins: Suppose
we change the subject.
I'm getting tired of this.
I vote the young lady
tells us a story.
>> Ellie Salins: I'm
afraid I don't know one.
>> Ken Salins: Then
the Dormouse shall.
Wake up, Dormouse.
>> Ellie Salins: And
they pinched it.
>> Ken Salins: On both
sides at once.
>> Ellie Salins: I wasn't asleep.
I heard every word,
every word you believe,
you were saying.
>> Ken Salins: You are sleeping.
>> Ellie Salins: I am sleeping.
>> Ken Salins: Tell us a story.
>> Ellie Salins: Yes, please do.
>> Ken Salins: And
be quick about it,
or you'll be asleep
again before it's done.
>> Ellie Salins: Oh,
once upon a time,
there were three little sisters,
and their names were
Elsie, Lacie, and Tillie.
And they lived at the
bottom of a well.
What did they live on?
They lived on treacle.
They couldn't have
lived on that, you know?
They'd have been ill.
They were very ill.
But why did they live
at the bottom of a well?
>> Ken Salins: Take some more tea.
>> Ellie Salins: I've had
nothing yet, so I can't have more.
>> Ken Salins: Then
you can't take less.
It's very easy to take
more than nothing.
>> Ellie Salins: Nobody
asked your opinion.
>> Ken Salins: Who's
making personal remarks now?
>> Ellie Salins: Alice did not
know quite what to say to this,
so she helped herself to some
tea and bread and butter.
>> Ken Salins: And then
turned to the Dormouse
and repeated her question.
>> Ellie Salins: Why did they
live at the bottom of a well?
It was a treacle well.
There's no such thing.
>> Ken Salins: Shh, shh.
>> Ellie Salins: If
you can't be civil,
you better finish the
story for yourself.
No, no, no, please, go on.
I won't interrupt again.
I dare say there may be one.
One indeed.
So these three little sisters, they
were learning to draw, you know?
Oh, what did they draw?
Treacle.
>> Ken Salins: I want a clean cut.
Let's all move down one place.
>> Ellie Salins: He
moved as he spoke,
and the Dormouse followed him.
The March Hare moved into the
Dormouse's place, and Alice,
rather unwillingly, moved to
the place of the March Hare.
>> Ken Salins: The Hatter is the
only one who got any advantage
from the change, and Alice was a
good deal worse off than before,
as the March Hare had just unset
the milk jug onto his plate.
>> Ellie Salins: But
I don't understand.
Where did they draw
the treacle from?
>> Ken Salins: You can draw
water out of a water well,
so I think you could draw a
treacle out of a treacle well.
Eh, stupid?
>> Ellie Salins: But
they were in the well.
Of course they were.
Well in.
>> Ken Salins: The answer
so confused poor Alice
that she let the Dormouse go on for
some time without interrupting it.
>> Ellie Salins: They were learning
to draw, and they draw all manners
of things, everything that
begins with an M. Why an M?
>> Ken Salins: Why not?
>> Ellie Salins: Hmm.
>> Ken Salins: The Dormouse had
closed its eyes by this time
and was going off into a doze.
But on being pinched by the
Hatter, it woke up again
with a little shriek and went on.
>> Ellie Salins: What begins
with an M, such as mousetraps
and the Moon and memory
and muchness.
You know a few things
are much of a muchless?
And ever so much a thing
as drawing a muchness?
Really now you ask
me, I don't think.
>> Ken Salins: Then
you shouldn't talk.
>> Ellie Salins: This piece
of rudeness was more
than Alice could bear.
She got up in great
disgust and walked out.
>> Ken Salins: The Dormouse
fell asleep instantly,
and neither of the others took
the least notice of her going.
Though she looked back
once or twice,
half hoping that they
would call after her,
the last time she saw
them, they were trying
to put the Dormouse into the teapot.
>> Ellie Salins: Well, at any
rate, I'll never go there again.
It's the stupidest tea party
I was ever at in all my life.
[ Applause ]
>> Would you like to tell
them what a treacle is?
>> Ellie Salins: I was going to
see if they knew what a treacle is.
Does anybody know what treacle is?
>> No.
>> Ellie Salins: No?
Does anybody know what molasses is?
What's molasses?
>> Me?
>> Ellie Salins: Yeah.
>> It's this kind of,
it's like a syrup.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Ellie Salins: Right.
>> Ken Salins: Did you all hear her?
Yeah.
>> Ellie Salins: She
said it's like a syrup.
It's sort of like a thicker syrup.
And treacle is sort
of the same thing.
In England, it's sort
of a thick syrupy thing.
So these three sisters
were in a well
with syrup, treacle sticky stuff.
That's what the story was about.
>> Ken Salins: Kind of silly.
>> Ellie Salins: Yeah, very silly.
Lots of silly things in the book.
Anybody know what a muchness is?
Much of a muchness?
I don't know what a
muchness is either.
Or why is a raven like
a writing desk?
Does anybody know?
A raven, what's a raven?
>> A bird.
>> Ellie Salins: A bird.
What color is it?
>> Black.
>> Ellie Salins: And what football
team has ravens as a mascot?
>> Baltimore.
>> Ellie Salins: Baltimore.
You guys got it.
Okay, so they're asking, why
is a raven like a writing desk?
So a writing desk is a desk that
Lewis Carroll would write things on.
So why could a raven
be like a writing desk?
So in the back, we have lots
of people from Lewis Carroll.
Does anybody have an
answer to that one?
There never was an
answer in the book.
But there's been some
studies about it.
So they wonder if it has
to do with the black ink
on the writing desk
and the black raven.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Ellie Salins: Were there any
questions about the chapter,
about Alice, about Lewis Carroll?
Does everybody know that
Alice was a real girl?
Do you all know that?
Yes? No? Alice was a real girl.
And she knew Lewis Carroll.
So Alice was-- Lewis
Carroll, let me back up,
Lewis Carroll was a math professor
at a university called
Oxford University in England,
and the college of the university
was called Christ Church,
which is a college, not a church.
And Lewis Carroll was
a math professor there.
And his boss, the dean of the
college, had a daughter named Alice.
>> Ken Salins: Dean is
kind of like a principal.
>> Ellie Salins: Yeah, the dean
of a college is like a principal.
So his boss's daughter was Alice.
And her name was Alice Little.
And he took Alice and two of her
sisters on a boat ride and made
up the story on the boat
ride that was in 1862.
And then in 1865-- well,
Alice really liked the story
on the boat ride, and she asked
him to write the story down.
So in 1865, he wrote it down,
and he handed it to her,
and it became published, and
it became Alice in Wonderland.
>> Ken Salins: She was
very close to your age.
How old are you all?
>> 11.
>> Ken Salins: 11.
She was 10.
>> Ellie Salins: She was 10 in 1862.
>> Ken Salins: Pretty close.
>> Ellie Salins: Was she 10 in 1862?
>> Ken Salins: Can you imagine going
on her adventure just a year ago?
Meeting all these strange
people [inaudible].
>> Ellie Salins: And the
book was first written,
it was called Alice's
Adventures Underground.
And then when they went to publish
it and make it a much, you know,
larger publication that all
sorts of people would read,
they changed the title to
Alice's Adventures in Wonderland.
So the real title is Alice's
Adventures in Wonderland.
And it was published in 1865.
So that's 151 years
ago, or 150 years ago.
Yep, 1865.
Do you guys have any questions?
>> Ken Salins: Has anybody read it?
Teachers? One?
>> Ellie Salins: Does anybody have
a favorite character from the book?
Who's your favorite character?
>> Mad Hatter.
>> Ellie Salins: Mad Hatter?
Who else? You have a
favorite character?
[ Inaudible ]
The Cheshire Cat?
The Cheshire Cat.
Yeah. Yep.
Say it a little louder?
[ Inaudible ]
The guy with the hat?
The Mad Hatter?
Okay, yep?
>> The bunnies.
>> Ellie Salins: The bunny?
The white rabbit or the March Hare?
>> The rabbit.
>> Ellie Salins: The rabbit, okay.
>> The March Hare.
>> Ellie Salins: The March Hare?
>> The Queen of Hearts.
>> Ellie Salins: The
Queen of Hearts.
The Queen of Hearts
yells at everybody.
That's a good one.
Anybody else?
Yeah? The Mad Hatter?
Okay.
>> Ken Salins: So for not having
read the book, you all know a lot
of characters from this book,
which is really interesting.
It's one of the reasons why there
are people who are interested
in this group 150 years later.
It's because it has
interesting characters in it.
So it's kept it alive
for a long time.
>> Ellie Salins: How many people
here have read Harry Potter?
Okay, you know that Harry Potter
and Lewis Carroll have a connection?
>> No.
>> Ellie Salins: No?
All right.
Would you like to know how?
>> Yes.
>> Ellie Salins: So this college
I talked about, Oxford University,
and then Christ Church is a college,
there's a big dining hall
called The Great Hall there.
How many people have seen
the Harry Potter, the first
or second Harry Potter movie?
And you saw The Hogsworth
Dining Hall?
They used the dining hall from
Christ Church for that movie.
So the Hogsworth Dining
Hall that you saw
in the movie was the same place that
Lewis Carroll ate his breakfast,
lunch and dinner every day
when he worked for the college.
Isn't that cool?
Yes.
>> Ellie Salins: That's
pretty cool, huh?
>> Ken Salins: Only the food
didn't float above his head.
>> Ellie Salins: The food
didn't float above his head, no.
But that's the connection.
When we went to see the movie,
we've been to this dining hall,
and I'm like, whoa,
that looks familiar.
Wait, I think they're
using the great hall.
It made it work.
It was really cool.
Any other questions?
Do the teachers have questions?
[ Inaudible ]
What the society does.
So we're the Lewis Carroll
Society in North America.
There's lots of Lewis
Carroll Societies.
There's one here.
There's one in England.
There's one in Japan.
We have a member of the Japanese
society here, Kimye [phonetic].
She came all the way from
Japan to be with you all.
There's Lewis Carroll
Society of Australia.
So there's lots of
Lewis Carroll Societies.
So we like to find out
things about Lewis Carroll
or about Alice or about
their families.
We collect things.
So my father has a
collection that started
in the 1890s by my grandfather.
She started collecting Alice
in Wonderland books
before Lewis Carroll died.
He died in 1898.
So the collection was first
started by my grandfather,
and then my father and
mother took it over.
And so you have a very
large book collection
that has how many different
languages now
of Alice in Wonderland?
>> Probably 70.
>> Ellie Salins: About
70 different languages.
And he has a lot of books that
are signed by Lewis Carroll.
[ Inaudible ]
And yes, so he is the
large motion picture Alice
in Wonderland movie collection.
And then we have other people.
Right now there's an exhibit
at University of Maryland
about the [inaudible] Alice
in Wonderland collection.
They're over here.
And so they have a very, very large
wonderful book collection too.
And a lot of people in this room
also have large book collections.
I have the largest Alice
in Wonderland teapot
collection in the world.
>> Ken Salins: The question was,
what the Lewis Carroll Society?
What do we do?
Why do we have this?
There's a lot of people
here that are inspired
by this book to do different things.
Some of them collect
books, as she said.
But there are artists around the
world that are always interested
in redoing some of the art.
The book you're going to have has
some of the original art in it.
But continuously, artists
are making new drawings
as they have been inspired by it.
There are people who are interested
in his life and his other hobbies.
He was a photographer.
>> Ellie Salins: And
a mathematician.
>> Ken Salins: So the people
get together and share stories
about what they learned
or how they've been
inspired by Lewis Carroll.
And so it's kind of a fun
thing to do, to get together
with other people who have a
hobby, the same hobby you have.
It's pretty much that, right?
>> Ellie Salins: Right.
But we all have a little bit
different spin on our hobbies,
like different interested.
Some people like Lewis Carroll
because he was a mathematician.
He wasn't an English teacher.
He was a math professor.
So some people like him for that.
Some people like him
for his writing.
Some people like him for
all different things.
He was a very interesting,
very intelligent man.
And there's a lot of
interesting stuff he did.
He was one of the first
photographers.
And he photographed a lot of
famous people back in the 1800s.
And so there's a lot of interest in
all different pieces that he's done.
>> Is there anyone in the room
who can tell them a little
bit about Jabberwocky?
>> Ellie Salins: About Jabberwocky?
What would you like to know?
>> Ken Salins: So he wrote more
than just Alice's Adventures
in Wonderland.
Jabberwocky was a poem
that he wrote.
You could probably do it.
>> Ellie Salins: I can do it.
Do you guys know the
poem Jabberwocky?
>> No.
>> Ellie Salins: Do
you want to hear it?
>> Sure.
>> Ellie Salins: Oh, man.
Are you guys going to
help me in the back there?
No? Oh, come on.
Okay, so Jabberwocky is from
Through the Looking Glass.
There were two books that
had to do with Alice.
One was Alice's Adventures in
Wonderland, and one was Alice
through the Looking Glass.
So all right, let's
see if I can do it.
'Twas brillig, and the slithy toves
did gyre and gimble in the wabe.
All mimsy were the borogoves,
and the mome raths outgrabe.
Beware the Jabberwock, my son!
The claws that bite,
the jaws that catch!
Beware the Jubjub bird, and
shun The frumious Bandersnatch!
He took his vorpal sword in hand;
Long time the manxome he fought.
And rested he by the Tumtum tree
and stood awhile in thought.
Oh, no, I missed a part.
You guys aren't helping me.
>> Ken Salins: So now you've got
to go to the library and read it.
>> Ellie Salins: So yeah,
you'll have to read it.
It's hard in front of an audience.
But that's the Jabberwocky.
And it's a very, very famous poem.
And a lot of people do it.
A lot of actors you can
find on YouTube and stuff,
a lot of actors are doing it
much better than I just did it.
Actors from England like to
do that poem there in England.
>> Ken Salins: It has a
lot of made-up words in it
that he just thought, that sounds
like it should be a word
and he put it in there.
And now some of the words that he
used just for playfulness are part
of everyday language,
which is really kind of a--
>> Ellie Salins: 'Twas brillig, and
the slithy toves did gyre and gimble
in the wabe, are any
of those English?
>> No.
>> Ellie Salins: But some of
those words have become words.
You hear people talk about--
>> Galumphing is a word.
>> Ellie Salins: And he
came galumphing back, yes.
>> And he chortled.
>> Ellie Salins: And he chortled.
He chortled as he came, yep.
I didn't say all those words.
So you had a question back there.
>> I was just wondering if
[inaudible] had any descendants
that are a part of The
Lewis Carroll Society.
>> Ellie Salins: So Lewis
Carroll never married
and had his own children,
but there are members
of The Lewis Carroll Society of
England that are nieces and nephews.
So a lot of his nieces and nephews,
yes, are part of the society.
>> Ken Salins: As a member of Christ
Church, he had to take his vows
of celibacy because he
was part of the church.
So he didn't have that.
>> Ellie Salins: When you
were a professor back then,
you weren't supposed to marry.
But I think when he was about
age 50, the rules changed.
But he was about 50,
and never married.
But yes, there are nieces and
nephews around, and they still have,
own some of his things,
and it's very interesting.
When you meet them, it's
kind of like meeting royalty.
So other questions?
>> Can you talk a little
bit about his childhood,
Lewis Carroll's childhood, and how
that seems to be the background
of what he was able to create?
>> Ellie Salins: Well, Lewis Carroll
was one of how many children?
>> 11.
>> Ellie Salins: 11 children.
And he was the oldest boy.
And so in order to keep 11 children
busy back in the early 1800s,
this is before any electronics.
There was nothing electronic.
There were no, you
know, cell phones,
iPhones, none of that back then.
So he did a lot of games.
He invented a lot of games that he
did with his brothers and sisters,
a lot of word games, a lot of
number games, a lot of, you know,
he would write plays,
he would draw pictures,
and did a lot to keep his
brothers and sisters busy.
>> Ken Salins: And he
made a little newsletter.
He started writing
at a very young age.
He made a little like newsletter
thing that he would publish.
And then they would have something
to read and they would sing games
and that would be the entertainment.
>> Ellie Salins: You had
a question back there.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Lewis Carroll, in the
original manuscript that he gave
to Alice Little in November of 1854,
and actually illustrated the book
himself, but he was concerned
that his drawings weren't good
enough for a published book.
So on the advice of friends,
he approached the punch
cartoonist John Tenniel.
[ Inaudible ]
He didn't become Sir John Tenniel
until much later in his life.
And Tenniel was a very famous man.
Lewis Carroll [inaudible]
was an unknown man teacher.
And Tenniel cooperated with him
and followed, to a great degree,
the original drawings that Lewis
Carroll had done, and those chapters
that are repeated from the original
manuscript in the published book.
And you can look at
them and see differences
and a great deal of similarities.
But Carroll was a little too modest.
Because some of his
illustrations are really brilliant,
especially the one when
Alice shrinks down so far
that her chin touches her shoes.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Ellie Salins: Did you all hear?
So Tenniel, the illustrations
that you're going to see
in the book we're going to give you,
was the original published
illustrations, okay?
But Lewis Carroll drew his own.
And they were beautiful.
They're really nice illustrations.
But then after Tenniel,
lots of different people
have now illustrated it.
But the other thing that
[inaudible] said was
that Lewis Carroll
was not his real name.
Lewis Carroll is a pen name.
Do you all know what a pen name is?
No? So some authors don't-- do you
want to explain what pen name is?
No? Okay, because you can
probably explain it better than me.
Some authors don't want people to
know they're the ones that wrote it.
So they could have one name.
So his real name, Lewis Carroll's
real name was Charles Lutwidge
Dodgson, okay?
Charles Dodgson.
And he was this famous
math professor.
And he's writing these
children's books, and he's like,
I don't want people to know I'm
writing these children's books.
So he came up with the name
Lewis Carroll as his pen name.
So that's the name he
used for children's books.
But sometimes when he
published other books,
because he published math books, he
would use the name Charles Dodgson.
But then he did other books
about symbolic logic
and all sorts of things.
And he sometimes used
Lewis Carroll for those.
But that was his pen name.
So his real name is Charles Dodgson.
So the person that had-- was one
of 11 kids was Charles Dodgson.
Then the writer of Alice in
Wonderland, Alice's Adventures
in Wonderland, is Lewis Carroll.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.